ce jeudi c'est la rentrée dans
l'académie de versailles 309 1089 élèves
yvelinois du premier et du second degré
vont revenir dans les salles de classe
après une pause estivale qui dit rentrée
dit nouveauté cette année ne dérogera
pas à la règle avec la crise sanitaire
l'une des priorités sera mis sur la
vaccination
60% des élèves de 12 à 17 ans sont
vaccinés dans l'académie selon les
derniers chiffres mais dans certaines
communes moins de 30 % des élèves sont
vaccinés on écoute charlie navlet la
rectrice de l'académie de versailles
nous lions chacun des 800 établissements
avec 84 centres de vaccination certains
qui sont nouveaux certains qui sont
anciens et en tout cas qui vont
permettre de mettre en oeuvre la
vaccination selon deux modalités soient
les élèves se déplace vers le centre de
vaccination ce sera la majorité des cas
soit nous ferons venir des équipes
mobiles des centres éphémère dans les
établissements donc tout cela est prêt
et nous sommes prêts à démarrer dès
cette semaine et le début de la semaine
prochaine sur la vaccination dès cette
rentrée l'académie expérimente également
le pass culture en milieu scolaire dans
six collèges avant qu'il soit lancé en
janvier partout en france le principe de
la 4e à la terminale les élèves ont
bénéficié de 200 euros pour leur
permettre de découvrir les milieux
artistiques et culturels explications
avec la rectrice nous allons déployer le
pass culture partout en france à partir
de janvier avec une part individuelle
c'est à dire je peux aller dans une
librairie acheter tél tél
tel livre dès lors que j'ai plus de 16
ans où je peux aller dans tel théâtre et
puis une part collective qui va être
mobilisée dans le cadre de projets
scolaires par exemple pour aller dans un
théâtre avec un groupe et avoir une
médiatisation spécifiques l'académie a
également annoncé d'autres nouveautés
pendant cette présentation il ya
notamment l'ouverture d'un nouveau
collège sur la commune de mantes la
jolie en plein coeur du quartier du val
fourré coût total 31 millions d'euros il
va accueillir 600 élèves dès ce mois de
septembre autre dossier un plan de lutte
contre les violences sexuelles et
sexistes va être lancée cette année dans
toute l'académie des formations seront
proposées au personnel